it is once again
time for some programmer mems
r slash programmer humor i'm just going
to react for a while
as a i guess as a c plus coder that's
mainly what i code in these days
so let's get into it let's see what we
got on this this special day
this is uh this is my 1 500 subscriber
special
thank you thanks for 1500 subscribers
i'm not losing my hair or anything over
it
no everything's fine everything's fine
all right let's see what we got see if
we can find some excellent humor
when i was four my sister was two i am
now 44 how old is my sister
programmer 44 minus 4 minus 2 equals 42.
tester this is a tough one she might be
42 she could be 41
also 43. since you don't say when your
birthday is and her birthday is she
could also be dead
finally you might have thought she was
your sister but actually your mom had an
affair with another man and a woman
as one minus three one to three years
younger than you
is not actually your sister but your mom
may have given away a real sister for
adoption
in which case she's probably older than
you see why it's tough
finally what if you think your sister is
dead but she actually became an
astronaut on a secret government
project for a near light speed travel
then your sister would be aging more
slowly than you
she could possibly she could potentially
be younger than 41.
yeah the programmer just types in the
obvious logic
uh this is it's not bad not a bad meme
sounds about right that's why you test
that's why you test
ah all right assembly developers be like
if you wish to make an apple pie from
scratch you must first invent the
universe
uh yeah it's already done
don't don't invent it just use a
programming language websites
when you scrape their content websites
when they install
cookies on your computer track your
browsing history
and mine bitcoin on your browser
give me three words better than i love
you
code compiled successfully
yeah that's better usually
senior developer just read the
documentation documentation
yeah that's about right it is it is
absurdly difficult to find
correct documentation i am good in c
language
then write hello world and see
clever hire this guy that was a bug not
me supervisor remember the format
you're supposed to comment when
committing to github
yes and why did you write cool changes
here
this cat's face when tech support
when tech support tells an engineer turn
it off and back on
do not cite the deep magic to me which
i was here when it was written dear
program
please grow up and solve your own
problems
i can definitely relate vaporwave
simulator
some video game channel if you use
cheats to clip through this area you
will find a model of a tomato
i wonder why they put this here me every
time
devs yeah when we take out the tomato
everything breaks so we just left it in
an interesting title people appreciating
how wikipedia is free linus torvalds
made the entire kernel free which runs
all android phones and servers
and probably wikipedia too hits compile
every fan in my computer
yep new clients
it's an old framework sure but at least
it's user friendly
their old framework what the heck is
that
that's annoying i was adding my
languages on this dating app
c plus nice
that's the only language you need to
know
you get lots of ladies for sure
confirmed
look at all of them back here
stop using print statements or debug as
debugging tools or draw
25 programmers i just spent 5 minutes
manually decoding
this binary message from season five of
silicon valley and it said
find a hobby for god's sake yeah i did
that once i checked the url and some
code they showed and it was
what we got
and watch the guilfoyle video if you
didn't because that's where it's at
press any key to continue
power button uh yeah that one's that
one's probably not gonna be the best one
to press
just press the the car key me leaving
area 51
knowing how to center vertically in css
oh that's a big brain real programmer
code
one zero and enter yeah that's all you
really need right
programmers before programming languages
oh this is the same mean
coders have long pretended
they know what they're doing really they
just search stuff on the internet for
how to do stuff
nations programmers admit they're
actually just really good at googling
things
well you got to learn somehow don't you
but how are you going to figure out
a new library with no documentation
intellisense that's how google searcher
software developer professional google
searcher
yeah i get it everyone thinks software
developers are just professional google
searchers that is only partly true
my point is you can't solve everything
with google you're going to run into
problems
that just don't have an obvious answer
on the internet and
you're just going to need enough side
knowledge and stuff
and maybe problem solving skills to
figure that out
so i learned that the hard way at one
point
but it totally makes sense so this meme
it used to really hit home when i was
like learning
to code originally but now just
architect verse developer
client balance these six nails without
letting
them touch the wood senior architect
developer ah that's that's nice
let's tape it together my code versus
stack overflow
my code code from stack overflow a nice
road
my good okay
the hn software development stands for
happiness
i see what you did there when code
your reading doesn't follow the same
formatting style that you are used to
uh that's when you why why do you care
about that
you just use an editor with like an auto
formatter that's got your settings and
just
hit the auto format button i just spent
five minutes manually decoding this oh
yeah that's this is the same meme
it's the same meme have we gone how deep
have we gone
have we gone to the very end being a dev
for hire in a nutshell
okay then made it worth it code my back
in code
me beautifying the front end
what is going on over there where's all
the smoke from
this is what i used to do until i saw
this comic
bile air compilar bio error file come on
come on
come on already you've recompiled the
same code
again should we stop well obviously it's
going to have the same error if you
haven't changed anything
it's funny how mad people get at code
sometimes
there's some tricks to that maybe i'll
make a video about that about how to
code without getting angry or something
stack overflow this is brilliant
official documentation stack overflow
answers official documentation
but i like this hey bro
after days of hard work i finally built
a website that's awesome
can you check it out localhost
slashlight looks great bro
that's gotta be a joke i mean like a
setup i don't know maybe it is a real
guy that actually thought
his friend would be able to get to his
local host the code doesn't work
panic he was just missing a semicolon
calm still doesn't work
panic how about this read the first
error
fix it don't panic
debugging skills my debugging skills
print
yo oh i see yeah i get it he's just
putting a print statement to make sure
kyle were supposed to go or whatever
these are all just like the same
recycled memes like these can all be
summarized as
um people use print to debug and they
shouldn't so we're gonna make memes
about it coders rage a lot
coders use stack overflow coders rage a
lot
coders don't actually know how to code
or are self-def
deprecating this one was actually good
coders rage a lot
i don't know some abstraction mean
that's not really funny coders are sad
and ragey
voters don't know how to code again just
the same recycled thing
just like pick three topics and make the
diff
this one was pretty good this testing
one all right let's go one more
one more deep how bad could it be oh
it's tech lead
well i'm so good at coding my wife left
me
now our marriage collapsed i think tech
leads a good guy
like obviously i don't know i'm only
know him through his videos but
his videos are really entertaining i
gotta give them that
oh and all the the other meme this was
the fourth topic
the one zero enter all right that's
gonna do it for this video
thanks for watching thanks again for
being here appreciate all of you guys
and uh matt from codetech tutorials out
peace